we all know the saying just buy and hold
whether the market goes up down sideways
or in circles you should forget about
the noise and a dollar cost average into
index funds and blue chip companies
while this strategy is a piece of cake
to follow during bull markets it often
gets a lot harder doing bear markets you
might hold it through a 20 30 40
correction but at some point most people
feel that continuing to invest is simply
hopeless they've seen the market tank
for weeks if not months on end due to
loads of selling pressure so clearly
someone is cutting losses and getting
the opportunity to buy back in lower
seeing this they stop buying or they
sell their positions as well to
hopefully buy back lower but for some
reason the stock just starts
skyrocketing the moment they sell
a perfect example of this was with jack
from the iced coffee hour on may 12 2022
jack announced that he had to sell all
of his robinhood stock because he got
margin called
commented so i went in on margin and i
bought some robin hood stock and then
the market started going down and it
continued to go down and uh yeah i got
margin called all because of robin hood
because of roberto
now ram was super excited because he has
a superstition that jack selling is
great for the market and while this may
seem like a silly belief somehow robin's
stock skyrocketed 38.4 the day this
video was posted now a robin hood is
still in an overall downtrend so for all
we know it may have months if not years
of downside left but it's still quite
astonishing that the stock made such a
move the moment that jack sold however
this isn't just some random coincidence
in fact most retail investors
experienced this same phenomenon during
every mark itself they might have been
diamond handing for months but the
second they sell it is the bottom so why
do stocks always skyrocket the moment
you sell
to understand why the stock market seems
to always work against you we have to
first understand who controls the market
whether you like it or not the stock
market and most financial markets are
controlled by large institutional
investors like market makers hedge funds
and investment bankers these guys use
their money to create various emotions
within the market and then they use
these emotions against the average
investor their strategy hasn't really
changed in decades but really there's no
need for them to even change their
strategy here's the thing while the
asset that people are buying or the
medium that they're buying it through
may change people's psychology remains
constant so regardless of the time
period or situation we see the same
cycles play out over and over again
every bull market starts out with the
stealth phase where smart money buys
into a promising investment this initial
phase of smart money investors usually
does not include the big hedge funds or
market makers rather this phase is
filled with innovators entrepreneurs and
maybe a bit of venture capital for
example steve jobs starting apple in the
1970s or jeff bezos starting amazon in
the 1990s would be considered a smart
money investment in most cases the
underlying investment is truly a good
purchase but the problem is that it
doesn't take too long for the investment
to get ahead of itself once the
innovators get the business off the
ground we see institutional investors
flood in
this is where the legendary investors
generally buy in like warren buffett and
peter lynch a lot of companies also tend
to invest during this time period for
example ford and amazon invested into
rivien during this phase
once all the institutional investors
were in they started going on tv and
talking about their investments in these
companies and this is when the average
retail investor first hears about this
investment if they went ahead and bought
instantly they would actually do quite
well but most retail investors are too
level-headed at this point to make the
decision they might look at the
financial metrics of a company or their
earnings reports and though they might
like the investment itself they usually
won't pull the trigger because they
don't feel the phone yet or the fear of
missing out their level-headed analysis
usually tells them that the investment
is selling for a premium and that they
should be able to get it for cheaper in
the future
meanwhile the more sophisticated retail
investor who's well aware of these
cycles knows that a cheaper opportunity
may never come so they go ahead and buy
in a great example of this in the real
world is tesla stock during mid-2020 at
the time the stock was selling at about
200 per share and while this may seem
like a great deal in retrospect 200 per
share was already paying a premium given
that the stock was at 60 dollars not
long before this but despite this these
guys won't have to wait too long to make
money as the party is just getting
started
after the sophisticated investors buy in
we see the degenerates join the party
during the enthusiasm phase these guys
generally have no idea what they're
doing as they're not exactly investing
based on logic or reason usually it's
just a case of they saw some guy on
youtube or tick tock make a lot of money
with the investment so they wanted to
join the party a great example of this
is buying dogecoin between 10 and 50
cents
meanwhile the average retail investor
knows that such ludicrous moves are
unsustainable and that it's just a
matter of time until these degenerates
get destroyed but at the same time they
also see these gamblers post insane
games on social media which gives them a
slight sense of fomo shortly after we
move into the greed phase and this is
when elephants like michael berry and
jeremy grantham wake up and start
calling the market a bubble these voices
of reason calms down the average retail
investor and justifies their choice to
sit out but despite their grand
predictions for an epic collapse the
market will just continue to roar on for
years and this is when the average
investor really starts to feel the fomo
what if the market crash never comes
what if this is the new normal what if
this time is different if you ever see
yourself asking this question you should
instantly stop yourself and not do what
you're wanting to do because this time
is never different but despite this as
we enter the delusion phase of the
market all signs will be pointing
towards this time being different
and unfortunately most retail investors
will give in to the fomo and buy in
at first they may even be up for a month
or two as we seemingly move into a new
paradigm but it doesn't take long for
smart money to start dumping their
positions you see it the influx of
retail investors gives big investors the
volume they need to offload their
massive positions without hurting the
market too much even with all the new
retail volume though the investment will
sell off a good amount due to the big
investors selling which brings us into
the denial phase
at this point the average investor isn't
down that much maybe 10 or 20 percent
but the first inklings of fear start to
set in some late retail investors who
didn't buy in during the delusion phase
will buy right now thinking that they're
getting a decent discount this buying
pressure will cause the investment to
rally back to where the average retail
investor bought in and the people will
think that we're finally returned to
normal but in reality the pain hasn't
even begun
as the market puts in a lower high and
volume starts to dry up some more
sophisticated retail investors will
start exiting their positions this would
be equivalent to when meet kevin sold
all of his positions near the beginning
of the year he didn't sell the absolute
top but he sold before the vast majority
of the pain showed up and as these
investors start offloading their
positions and no new buyers show up the
investment starts to sell off once again
leading to market fear
while the average investor is feeling
quite fearful at this point they feel
that they're too deep to cash out right
now they might already be down 40 or 50
percent and they feel that things can't
get much worse right
well they can and that's exactly what
happens next as the market capitulates
this is when we see those 70 80 crashes
like we saw on netflix and paypal
during this capitulation the vast
majority of retail investors will sell
out either due to extreme fear or being
margin called and the people who hold on
will enter a phase of despair a perfect
example of this in the real world is
when bitcoin settled down at 3 000 to 4
000 after running to 20 grand during
this phase your investment was seemingly
having no hope and you'll probably be
made fun of for holding such an
investment in reality this is the best
time to be buying in but no one will
care to do so and the few remaining
retail investors will finally give in
and cash out the little they have left
as the last retail investors are flushed
out though a new set of smart money will
become interested once again
the most recent example of this is fdx
founder sam bankmann buying into
robinhood at basically book value so
it's not a coincidence that you always
end up buying the top and selling the
bottom through every step in the market
cycle smart money manipulates the market
and your emotions to make you do exactly
this they buy right after retail
investors are flushed out and they sell
right when retail investors re-enter the
market and they repeat this over and
over and over again
something else to consider is that even
if you don't get crushed by market
cycles like the average investor it's
likely that you'll still have the same
feeling that stocks skyrocket the moment
you sell due to human psychology our
brains are wired to remember the times
that we messed up or missed out on
something meanwhile we forget all the
times that we made the right call a
personal example of this happening to me
is during the gamestop run in early 2021
i became aware of the gamestop situation
relatively early when the stock was at
about 60
so i put 840 into a degenerate call and
it actually ended up working out the
following week i upped the ante a bit
and bought some more degenerate calls
for 6 500
within a matter of hours this position
skyrocketed to 14 750
i was torn between swinging the position
overnight or just locking in the profits
i ended up playing it safe and locking
in the profits but just a few hours
after i sold elon musk would tweet
gamestonk and the stock would moon to
nearly 500
if i had decided to simply swing the
degenerate calls overnight i would have
made a hundred thousand dollars as i
would have definitely sold the first
thing the next morning and looking back
this puts me in a really ironic position
instead of being grateful that i made
eight thousand two hundred fifty dollars
which is a phenomenal amount or being
thankful that i didn't buy the top i'm
over here being salty that i didn't make
another eighty thousand dollars now on
the other hand what if a game stop had
crashed right after i sold i probably
would have written off my degenerate
trade as a good call and forgotten about
it but since i sold it right before such
a monumental event took place the trade
has become something that i'll probably
never forget and i bet that this same
sentiment applies to most investors as
well
we'll forget about the dozens or
hundreds of times that we made it by
call by selling but you can bet they'll
remember the few times we missed out and
psychologically these few times will
overshadow all of our great calls making
it seem like we always saw right before
stock skyrocket when in reality that's
simply not the case
at the end of the day market cycles and
human psychology are extremely difficult
to navigate even if you're aware of all
of this it's basically a coin flip when
it comes to making the right decision
when the time comes and while some
investors have managed to overcome these
challenges the average investor will
never overcome these mind games and
that's why dollar cost averaging is by
far the best strategy for all of us even
though there's so much noise within each
market cycle the one thing that remains
constant is that the mean is constantly
increasing
and as long as you're putting money into
fundamentally strong investments the
means should only go up over the long
term also by dollar cost averaging the
same amount of money on a regular basis
you'd naturally be buying more shares
when the market is down and less sure is
when the market is up and you didn't
even have to spend any effort in trying
to time the bottom or top so the next
time you feel like stocks moon right
after you sell or that stocks crash
right after you buy this should be a
strong signal that you should be timing
the market less and dollar cost
averaging more but that's just what i
think have you guys ever sold the bottom
or bought the top comment that down
below also drop a like if you're a fan
of dollar cost averaging and of course
consider checking out our international
channels to watch the videos in other
languages and consider subscribing to
see more questions logically answered
but until then i'm hari and i'll see you
guys on the next one
you